. This is very interesting.
We have the first approval rating for President
Joe Biden.
It's 63 percent.
This is the highest approval rating at any
time for any president dating back 12 years
to 2009 to find an approval rating for a president
higher than Joe Biden's current approval rating
of 63 percent.
You have to go all the way back to 2009, Barack
Obama's first year in the White House when
Obama hit 69 percent approval.
Note that Donald Trump never got to even 50
percent approval, even one time during his
entire presidency.
Now, there's a couple of different things
going on here.
There is such a dramatic shift in covid policy,
which is one of the top issues for most Americans
right now from Trump, who couldn't have failed
more miserably to Biden, who is at least trying.
And we'll see what degree of success he has.
I think covid explains a lot of the shift
to a high approval rating for Joe Biden.
In addition, presidents often have their best
approval ratings at the very beginning before
they've done things that their political opponents
can say are bad or done, things that are actually
bad.
George W. Bush was different in that way.
George W. Bush's approval rating skyrocketing,
I think, to eight was it 88 percent after
9/11, which was not which was a bit of a ways
in Munsen to George W. Bush's presidency.
But typically, this is when January, February,
March of their first term.
This is when presidents have their highest
approval.
So it's not totally shocking that Biden's
doing OK.
Now, the fact that he's at 63 percent is quite
interesting.
We've not seen an approval that high for a
president in 12 years now being realistic.
Biden probably settles below 63 percent.
If he can really turn the pandemic around
in the next four to six months, maybe he could
get to 68, maybe he could get to 70.
Remember that right now, about 30 percent
of this country is completely whack a do OK.
And it's very hard for me to imagine that
Biden ceiling is much higher than 70 or 72
percent anyway.
So maybe a successful Biden can peak at sixty
seven, sixty eight, maybe 70, and a successful
Biden would probably settle somewhere around
the mid 50s.
If he does well, if he does as poorly as Trump
than you'd expect to see him in the high 30s,
low 40s, the way that Donald Trump does, the
real test for Biden will be these next three
to six months.
What happens with the virus?
What happens with vaccination when we are
up now up to a one in a quarter million vaccinations
a day, which is great.
And what happens when unemployment expires
for a lot of people?
There are some major tests coming for Joe
Biden.
But these early numbers, very, very interesting
to see.
And at least to the degree that a hyper polarized
country can be united behind what a president
is doing, 63 percent approval and 69 percent
approval of covid so far in this first week,
it is significant to pretend it's not what
would be dismissive of something that is significant.
This is when you expect to see presidents
with some of their higher approvals.
Let's check in again about this in four to
six weeks.
Let's take a quick break.
Make sure you're following the show on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman, The David Pakman Show
at
David
Pakman dot com.
Welcome back to the The David Pakman Show.